[Musique]
longtemps pour plusieurs autochtones
c'était pas nécessairement une fierté
d'affirmer son identité
mais dernièrement le coming out
autochtone est à la mode
il ya vraiment beaucoup de gens ilan
university et demi est un institut de
travail il se prétend du matin parfois à
tort et à travers mais pour plusieurs
membres des premières nations tout cela
assez duré voilà la vie comme aimait
tant de maisons qu est la plus proche
ancêtre autochtone remontent parfois au
temps de la colonisation
mais il assure que la culture s'est
transmise de génération en génération
lorsque vous affirmez comme métis de nos
jour automatiquement vous tombez sous la
loupe ou mais d'où ça vient
qui exactement lequel dans notre
suffisamment mais même le gouvernement
fédéral est elle capable de dire qui est
métis et qui ne l'est pas et certains
tentent de profiter de la situation
évidemment n'importe qui peut se dire
n'importe quoi si je veux me dire extra
terrestre je peux me dire extraterrestes
la question c'est qui va te croire
ici marie maude denis bienvenue à
enquête
[Musique]
salut joe des watts au conseil ou
conseil des abénakis d'odanak sommes le
15 septembre
il va ailleurs
ce n'est pas de mise en demeure qui va
empêcher jacter watts au de parler
l'homme en a fait son combat dénoncé
ceux qui se prétendent faussement
autochtone selon lui un vol d'identité à
ses yeux il menti à ma nation rotana
s'est servi de la culture pour ramasser
sa carrière il se dit un grand allié
culturelle des premières nations
[Musique]
celui qui menace de poursuites c'est
luis silva ribar c'est un spécialiste du
vêtement autochtone bien connu dans les
médias les milieux culturels et les
musées et des couteaux de coups de
couteau coup ce sont les couteaux sont
portés là cette interdiction d'importer
au coût plutôt qu'à la taille la latence
est allé voter pour jacques watts au
sylvain rivard est un imposteur
un exemple parmi bien d'autres selon lui
de plus en plus de gens s'identifient
métis au pays se regroupent et exige des
droits mais qui est ou n'est pas métis
d'une question simple beaucoup de
réponses on le cultive tout la majorité
de la communauté de l'occuper mais quand
on commence à poser des questions
litigieuses if sur le sujet sylvain
rivard est un artiste multidisciplinaire
hauteur et compte a reconnu
on peut l'apercevoir ici en allemagne
lors d'un festival
il fait aussi des présentations dans les
écoles
[Applaudissements]
ces comptes sont publiés par une maison
d'édition autochtone en 2019 au salon du
livre de montréal
il est entouré d'eau tard autochtone
dont joséphine bacon la grande pauvreté
réelle d'être ici nous ça comme sauter
une génération la joie y est mes amis
nous l'histoire jeu sylvain rivard
collabore depuis des années avec la
nation abénaquise il a même appris la
langue au musée d'odanak il a grandement
contribué à l'exposition l'indien au
delà de woods mais son ascendance
autochtone n'est pas clair s'il va
rivard si longtemps présenté comme ayant
des origines abénaquise mais il a cessé
de le faire
il maintient avoir des ancêtres
autochtone mais encore aujourd'hui il
est incapable de les préciser
ce livre est devenu plus grand sur
mensonge
et puis les goûts artistiques
culturelles de son appropriation
identité culturelle de ma nation ont
fait en sorte que c'est devenu un
personnage qui est représentatif de
l'appropriation culturelle chinois silva
rivard a refusé de nous accorder une
entrevue à la caméra joint au téléphone
il dit ne pas avoir menti car sa grand
mère lui a toujours dit qu'il avait des
origines autochtones
il a le sentiment d'être autochtone
depuis son enfance et d'un train
ambassadeurs de la culture des premières
nations et le grand argument tassé que
je fais sur pour honorer les premières
nations chose qui est pas le court parce
que ce sont des prédateurs et culturel
qui viennent dans nos communautés qui
exploitent notre richesse culturelle qui
doit être diffusée que par nous les
parures nation
[Musique]
d'autres membres des premières nations
ont tenu à prendre la défense de sylvain
rivard par communiqué il affirme que
même s'il n'a pas de statut autochtone
il en a l'esprit le coeur et l'âme
les signataires souhaitent même que ce
dériveur devienne membre de la nation
abénaquise à titre honorifique de
laurence contre emi gwan est une artiste
et pédagogue spécialiste des coutumes
autochtone
son but créer des rapprochements
interculturels je dirais que cette
entrevue en 2015
elle parle de ses origines avec
l'animateur d'une web tv à la maison par
les noms anglais de baragouin mythe
chiffres c'est un non autochtone entre
coupe de france est un peu d'anglais ok
donc c'était la langue maternelle de
laure est contré l'auteur du livre une
pédagogie de la spiritualité
amérindienne ses activités
professionnelles ont été soutenus par
des organismes et institutions du québec
du manitoba et aussi de la france c'est
mon grand père qui avait quitté
l'ontario lui étant d'un jeune anishnabe
avec son épouse aussi moi j'ai pas vu
d'ascendance algonquine de son côté les
générations dominique riccio spécialiste
en généalogie n'a pas trouvé d'un cintre
anishnabe algonquine dans la famille de
dollars est contré d'ailleurs mme iguane
sinon d'un autochtone que la fréquenter
il y a plusieurs années ils ont vu un
enfant mais ne se sont jamais mariés
au moment de son entrevue d'embauché
madame contre y aura effectivement
mentionné qualité métis dollar est
contré et chargés de cours sur les
traditions coutumes et croyances des
autochtone à l'université de montréal
depuis 2008 être autochtone ou métis
n'est pas un critère d'embauché mais
l'université analysera quand même le
cadre de leur est contré
si on doit finir par exemple sur notre
site internet où effectivement elle
s'affiche comme mitis on le fera mais on
doit poursuivre l'ialie différentes
vérifications l'heure en ce sens le
dollar us contre il n'a jamais répondu à
nos demandes d'entrevue par courriel son
fils affirme que sa mère n'a rien fait
de mal
selon lui elle a simplement voulu
honorer son père en lui transmettant la
culture algonquine
je suis l'humain femme-médecin de la
première nation en taillant abonnés qui
a good thing du québec
j'en profite pour saluer tous les
membres de mon clan la chamane le
marocaine se dit porteuse de la médecine
duclair esprits inspiré des pratiques
ancestrales autochtone l'univers
s'exprime poney en français ou d'autres
la s exprime en vibration et infarctus
ou marocaines ou diane tremblay de son
vrai nom affirme descendre d'un chef
pierrot quoi et que son grand-père est
autochtone notre généalogistes n'a
toutefois trouvé aucun ancien 30 octobre
dans sa lignée c'est du n'importe quoi
c'est du fast food culture scd gallas
puis même ceux qui font la pauvre casse
l'appropriation culturelle ils font bien
ça justifie pour leurs mensonges
diane tremblay refusé de nous accorder
une entrevue à la caméra au téléphone
elle affirme que les registres publics
sont erronées elle dit avoir comme seul
objectif d'aider les gens dans le besoin
d'autres personnalités publiques ont
aussi fait la manchette récemment
[Musique]
la directrice est identifié micmacs et
métiers salgon keane
la presse révélait que son ancêtre
autochtone le plus proche traîner en
1680 nadine saint louis a intenté une
poursuite contre la presse son avocat
nous a fait savoir que les informations
diffusées dans les médias sont fausses
et diffamatoires
[Musique]
michel la tumeur une réalisatrice
canadienne bien connu dans le milieu du
cinéma
une enquête de siby ci a remis en
question ses origines liées à la
première nation de kitigan zibi près de
maniwaki
madame la témoin s'est excusé d'avoir
affirmé être originaire de cette
communauté sans d'abord avoir fait
toutes les vérifications nécessaires
elle maintient tout de même être métisse
l'eau nf ensuite retiré son documentaire
in cannes l'union indienne de son
catalogue
[Musique]
la conseillère municipale marie josée
parents première réduit autochtone à la
ville de montréal qui portait le dossier
de la réconciliation avec les premiers
peuples
jusqu'à ce qu'un article de radio canada
va mettre en doute ses racines
autochtones la force à se retirer du
comité
les réseaux sociaux ont réagi beaucoup
il ya une dizaine de jours grâce ou à
cause d'éric pouliot teasé puisque c'est
vous eric qui avait sorti 7 des
affirmations là sur internet donc
marie-josée parents ne sont pas ni ac
éric pouliot tisdale et mohacs un
passionné de généalogie sur son site
internet il dénonce des personnalités
publiques qui usurpent l'identité
autochtone selon lui c'est vraiment un
fantasme et puces si on n'y croit pas on
n'est pas correct sa méthode publier
l'arbre généalogique des gens
à chaque publication les réactions sont
vives sur les réseaux sociaux
il ne se prétendant 7 micmac dans cet
avion qui se paie finalement faire
généalogie puis on remonte à 1600 1615
mon expérience de l'année dernière a été
vraiment traumatisante à ça est
extrêmement blessé
un an plus tard marie josée parents
accepté de revenir sur les événements
comme c'est souvent le cas chez les
personnes s'identifier un métis elle
affirme que son sentiment d'appartenance
à la nation micmac lui vient d'abord
d'une tradition orale familiale une
culture qui m'a été transmise et que je
vis encore aujourd'hui qui m'a été
racontée qui m'a dit qu'ils m'ont été
inculquées par mes parents en quête de
preuves
elle a consulté des experts pour
reconstruire de façon factuelle donc
avec des preuves
l'histoire familiale qui m'a été
racontée et est systématiquement cette
histoire le et maintenant corroborée par
des faits historiques avec des
certitudes défense des certificats de
mariage une généalogie complète comme ce
certificat de naissance de son
arrière-grand-mère
un élément que je n'avais pas et donc
c'est quand même super intéressant de
voir qu'elle a été baptisée sur la
réserve de lennox island notre
généalogistes assure que ce certificat
ne signifie pas que son arrière grand
mère était autochtone pour autant dans
les différents recensements public son
arrière grand mère ne s'est d'ailleurs
jamais identifié comme étant autochtone
rien de surprenant pour marie-josée
parents bien sûr que plusieurs
autochtones ont longtemps cacher leur
identité
je vous avoue que j'en ai appris tout ce
que j'ai appris sur le caractère
historique qui n'est pas toujours
raconter ou qui est moins bien connue
sur la réalité du territoire d'où je
viens j'ai envie de le célébrer
davantage
au pays on assiste à une véritable
explosion du nombre de personnes
s'identifiant métis selon le recensement
de 2016
ils étaient 5 187 milles une
augmentation de 3 134% en 25 ans au
québec
69 mille personnes se disent métis une
hausse de 150% en disant on n'en
revenaient toujours hélas même
historique 5 à 6 en sept que
généralement environ 60 à 80 % des
québécois ont entre 1600 et 1670
approximativement donc excessivement
loin
même le premier ministre du québec dit
posséder l'un de ses anciens projets une
de mes arrière grands mères arrière
arrière arrière grand mère qui s'appelle
ma vie me tais oui migou coups dont qui
était algonquine
[Musique]
le premier ministre ne se disent pas
métis pour autant mais des membres des
premières nations à qui nous avons parlé
se sont dit en français par sa
déclaration
partout ils tombent sur des québécois
animé d'un nouveau sentiment de
légitimité
ce phénomène massif de coming out
autochtone même bien intentionnés
devient épuisant et insupportable pour
eux il ya vraiment beaucoup de gens
inami astiquer les milieux médiatiques
domine il est un instru de travail et se
prétend de sourds ce truc tonnes de
région le docteur
c'est qu'on descend d'un petit art hogan
leurs ports c'est une fois une autre
forme de colonialisme l'apport des
canadiens français seulement du grand
mère nature ses blessures
après la pause on va à la rencontre de
beaucerons qui se disent métis et qui
revendiquent des droits notamment pour
la production de sirop d'érable
[Musique]
les métis revendiquent les mêmes droits
que les premières nations
il ya même une centaine d'organisations
qui sont allés en cours pour tenter de
se faire reconnaître officiellement mais
vous allez voir que ça pas été un succès
on a décidé de vous donner un tas de
mocassins parce que c'est symbolique
l'idée c'est de vous dire de vous
demander de chaussées de mocassins avec
notre regard sur la vie
[Musique]
dominic côté la chef d'une association
regroupant des médecis en beauce la
nation sartigan mois à l'école
m'appelait la grosse quoi c'était
vraiment le quotidien de ce que je
vivais dans ma vie même à 10 12 13 14
heures dominic côté a d'abord fondé la
communauté en thaï ha en 2007 puis le
groupe s'est séparé aujourd'hui 150
membres ont suivi la chef côté et
forment la nation sartigan dominic côté
affirment que c'est sa grand mère qui
lui révèle ses origines autochtones une
communauté oublié par l'histoire et un
village disparu aujourd'hui saint victor
de beauce
[Musique]
elle sait révèle la vérité sur notre
gros et comment je peux révéler la
vérité sur notre groupe en faisant un
rapport historique c'est ce qu'on a fait
à la nation en démontrant saut et 2 c en
obtenant notre connaissance avec intérêt
au québec il y à 11 nations autochtones
reconnus par le gouvernement fédéral les
membres de ces communautés ont au
minimum un an cintres autochtone à moins
de trois générations les organisations
de métis comme celle de dominique côté
ne sont pas reconnus et n'ont pas de
droit autochtone mais beaucoup militent
tout de même pour les obtenir
et cette reconnaissance là je laisse pas
va permettre entre autres qu'on peut
savoir une bonne collaboration tant avec
les communautés à une église tout un
accueil linak puisqu'on est cousin on ne
sortait des mêmes ça c'est des cousins
que les abénakis ne reconnaissent pas
dominer côté à l'approché de conseil
dans sa première organisation en taille
en 2006 le dossiste un petit document
vous dînez avec comme un petite école
c'était pour cet impôt et exceptionnels
comme documents de preuves historiques
en décembre 2019 jacques huacho émet ce
communiqué au nom de sa nation on y
mentionne que la chef côté son groupe
sont des usurpateurs d'identité
j'ai dit que je comprends c'est son
inquiétude est que je comprends qu'avec
tous les gros qui existe c'est difficile
de s'y retrouver
en effet difficile de s'y retrouver
les associations métis comme la nation
sartigan il y en a pratiquement dans
toutes les régions de la province
est-ce possible qu'il y ait autant de
communautés métisses oublié par
l'histoire
les avis des chercheurs différent sur ce
point selon les données archivistique
historique que j'ai consultés pour moi
en tant que spécialistes et experts sur
la question il n'y a aucun doute qu'il y
ait des métis au québec
sébastien malades s'identifient lui-même
métis professeur à l'université carleton
en outaouais il étudiait ces groupes qui
tentent de se faire reconnaître
pour lui il faut regarder les groupes
métis au cas par cas avec deux autres
chercheurs il vient de publier le livre
les bois brûlé de l'outaouais qui fait
état de l'origine des métis de cette
région
je crois que la plupart des individus
viennent vers ces groupes là avec des
identités et des motifs qui sont
distincts qui sont plurielles multiples
oui il peut y en avoir des gens qui
peuvent avoir des mauvaises intentions
mais c'est pas à mettre tous dans le
même sens
d'abord le roux fait une autre lecture
du mouvement métis en 2019 il a publié
ce livre bientôt traduit en français des
blancs qui revendique une identité
autochtone dame leroux les appels des
wesh shifter des autochtones
autoproclamé le professeur à
l'université saint mary's à halifax
n'hésite pas à remettre en question
l'authenticité de ces groupes dans l'est
du pays au québec j'en ai trouvé environ
30 à 35 qui sont présentement actifs en
nouvelle écosse il ya environ 10
nouveaux brand lui qui a sept ou huit
qui vont en cours normalement ans pour
plus pour accéder à essayer d'accéder à
des droits autochtones
[Musique]
pour obtenir des droits autochtones
avoir 20 ans entre dans sa lignée et
être membre d'une association métis ne
suffit pas il faut faire la preuve que
l'on appartient à une communauté métisse
historique ni droits autochtones au
canada sont des droits collectifs
uniquement si vous voulez avoir des
droits il faut vous soyez une communauté
et sous les droits vont être accordée à
la communauté et non pas à des individus
[Musique]
denis gagnon a été directeur de la
chaire de recherche sur l'identité
métissée à l'université saint boniface à
winnipeg pour lui l'identité métis est
une richesse donc il faudrait prendre
soin les médecins savaient aussi bien la
colonie de la rivière rouge peinte
ulysse est un terme générique désigne
éthique en possède des origines
européennes et autres échoppes partout
au canada
[Musique]
la communauté qui va obtenir des droits
doit démontrer qu'elle a une culture
commune des coutumes et traditions qui
constitue l'identité métis différente
des premières nations et des européens
est prouvé que cette tradition a perduré
dans le temps c'est le test parler un
jugement de la cour suprême qui a fait
jurisprudence au canada et la
collectivité métis de sault ste marie
ont réussi ce test avec succès en 2003
et ainsi obtenu des droits autochtones
un jugement qui a enflammé le mouvement
mais disent partout au pays et beaucoup
demandent aux communautés au canada qui
vont lire les critères et qui se
reconnaissent ils se disent on est
toujours tourné comme ça c'est ce qu'on
a vécu c'est notre histoire
donc ils se sont reconnus et sont dit on
pourra avoir des droits nous aussi comme
à sault sainte marie près de 110
associations au québec et au canada se
sont tournés vers les tribunaux confiant
d'obtenir une reconnaissance et des
droits généralement des droits de chasse
ou de pêche alors que dominic côté était
chef de la communauté métisse en taille
à certains de ses membres souhaitaient
pouvoir produire sirop d'érable sans
être soumis aux règles en vigueur
moi j'avais personnellement écrit l ups
que je le demandais c'était un quota
particulier pour la nation mais c était
refusé c'est juste une question d'argent
encore l'eau mais à force de répéter des
mensonges sont devenus des indiens dans
leur car il se lève puis la sauge
pompiers partent un ferme qu'ils louent
je présente note dans ce sens
traditionnel de la nation mario turgeon
en dansant traditionnels un conseil un
cercle des aînés la nation certes
higuain est à l'image des premières
nations
autant de gestes pour retrouver des
racines essais libres une culture parce
que c'est quelque chose que vous auriez
fait dans vos traditions nomades
moi je n'avais pas cueilli par les
danses à deux pas des palabres et
respectueux c'est une cérémonie
si grammaire tactiles sont très très
très très loin parce que si c'est 3 à
100 dans ce tract normandeau au xviie
siècle
dominique riccio n'a trouvé aucun
document démontrant que la grand-mère de
dominer côté serait autochtone comme
elle le prétend c'est très difficile de
faire les recherches amérindiens non
seulement c'est pas indiquée mais il
change de nom on les efface né de
parents inconnus
vous savez vous me dites bon votre
généalogie sera pas trouvé ma g à un
moyen de la trouvé dernièrement alors
c'est pour vous dire comment ça a été
très très compliqué c'est un début le
yacht en histoire ce quelqu'un un
autochtone te dis c'est compliqué ma
généalogie c'est pas compliqué c'est
parce qu'il c'est un mensonge n'y a rien
de cacher ou de mystérieuses cet
événement là les gens devaient très
sensible les gens vous le savoir et
qu'ils avaient affaire aussi c'est
important aussi d'avoir un nez sur une
population qu'on essaie de contrôler
faut que tu acceptes comme métis
sébastien mallette est d'avis que même
ceux n'ayant aucun danse entre
autochtones ont le droit de s'identifier
comme etis
pour lui il faut aller au delà de la
généalogie et considérer leur façon de
vivre et de voir le monde
les critères généalogique ça mène à des
chasses aux sorcières est-ce que vous
avez véritablement ses ancêtres l'eau ou
non est ce qui vient très exactement des
familles algonquine ou abénaquise
selon le registre public saint fort aux
tapas qu est né au xviie siècle serait
le plus proche ancêtre autochtone de
sébastien mallette
une information qui est faux selon celui
qui dit accorder davantage d'importance
à ce que lui a transmis son père c'est
souvent le cas chez les métis en fait
pas tout seul là dedans la plupart des
métis vont connaître une transmission
culturelle familiale
on a souvent cet historique lot des
défis des histoires de famille où les
gens disent oh ma grand mère nous disait
qu'on avait du sang indien et cetera et
cetera
mais ce vaste de mythologie canadienne
française québécoise qui est basé sur
une ascendance qui remonte aux années
1600 lorsque vous affirmez comme métis
dojo automatiquement vous tombez sous la
loupe vous tombez sous la loupe par
exemple de journalistes comme vous ou de
spécialistes qui viennent vous voir et
qui vous disent mais d'où ça vient qui
exactement
lequel ça fait combien de temps un temps
note suffisamment la majorité des
associations médecis émettent une carte
de membre
dominic côté avait la sienne quand il
était chef de la communauté en taille à
des cartes souvent semblable à la carte
officielle émise par le fédéral aux
indiens statuer certains utilisent
frauduleusement leurs cartes métis pour
être exempté de taxe sur leurs achats
comme une voiture neuve par exemple on
va vraiment a créé la carte ont
rassemblé au tac possible à la carte
réelle et on voit qu'il ya un montant de
fraude dans l'utilisation de sa carte
assez élevé aujourd'hui la nation
sartigan mener mais plus de cartes à ses
membres
justement parce que la chef côté dit
avoir constaté des cas de fraude
j'ai moi même fait le tour des commerces
avec un document sur la loi sur les
indiens expliqué
actuellement droit au lieu la déduction
1 d'une part l'autre chose que j'ai fait
ce que j'ai comme qui aussi avec les
gardes-chasse pour leur expliquer que
t'as pas le droit de chasser et pêcher
n'importe où au moment où tu détiens une
carte telle que celle où
[Musique]
la chamane nous marocaine est aussi
membre de la nation sartigan comme
titulaire de ce village là on va de
pouvoir donner utiliser le mot premières
et tout ça c'est en cours
à ce jour seule la communauté de sault
ste marie en ontario a réussi le test
parler les 110 autres groupe métis ont
tous échoué dans leur tentative de se
faire reconnaître juridiquement
au québec le plus retentissant procès a
eu lieu au saguenay-lac-saint-jean le
chasseur ghislain corneau refusait de
démolir son camp de chasse sur les
terres publiques puisqu'il se disait
métis près de 12000 personnes de trois
organisations et ils se sont jointes à
lui pour revendiquer des droits
autochtones
après plus de onze ans procédure la cour
d'appel a rejeté leur demande le juge
conclut ainsi pour plusieurs
s'identifier comme métis ne correspond
souvent à rien de plus qu à la
reconnaissance d'un métissage biologique
remonte à l'époque coloniale sans égard
aux moindres aspects culturels et
communautaires relié à ce statut social
je pense entre un dieu qui a pas des
gens mixer de personnes meetic sont
autochtone évidemment s'il coll ce que
je dis ce qui a pas de peuple distingue
métis le problème c'est qu'il ya eu des
efforts par les gouvernements par le
passé pour éteindre ces communautés là
dont on demande aujourd'hui de faire
démonstration de leur existence
donc il me semble que le gouvernement
ont un problème à savoir de demander à
des gens de prouver une identité qu'elle
a tenté d'évacuer et même d'éliminer
pendant 200 300 ans
tout est fait pour accéder à des droits
de pêche de chasse
peut-être c'est pour accéder à des
programmes d'emploi
peut-être c'est simplement pour une d un
désir ambigu d'honorer ses ancêtres mais
ce qui est important c'est que les
premiers peuples disent que ce n'est pas
acceptable on retourne notre
collaboratrice temps d'obtenir sa carte
de membre d'une organisation qui
représente des métis et découvre par le
fait même quelques cousins éloignés
[Musique]
pour devenir membre d'une association
métis et avoir une carte il faut remplir
un formulaire fournir la preuve que vous
avez un ancêtre autochtone parfois une
simple déclaration sur l'honneur suffit
puis payer les frais qui varie entre 40
et 260 dollars selon l'association une
cotisation annuelle est exigée nous
avons voulu vérifier à quel point il est
facile ou pas d'obtenir la carte de
l'association
nous avons demandé à une collaboratrice
de tenter l'expérience à sa connaissance
elle n'a aucun ancêtres autochtone dans
sa lignée elle remplit tout de même les
formulaires pour devenir membre de la
plus importante organisation
représentant des métis dans la province
l'alliance autochtones du québec
fondée dans les années soixante dix
l'alliance autochtones du québec anne
longue histoire de conflit interne au
milieu des années 2000 l'association et
même au bord de l'éclatement
le nouveau chef guillaume carle mène une
guerre sans merci contre des membres
influents de l'organisation une série de
retentissants procès et de réunion
houleuse
[Musique]
par la suite ce même guillaume carle a
fondé sa propre association
son organisation a fait l'objet d'une
enquête de cilicie en 2018
le chef car recrutait des membres en
faisant analyser leur adn en laboratoire
siby ci a révélé que les résultats
étaient plus que douteux l'adn de
collègues né en russie et en inde et
même de la bave de chiens contenait des
gènes autochtone 12 pour sabine acquise
et 8% work
guillaume carle poursuit sivici en
diffamation pour ce reportage
l'alliance autochtone est la seule
association représentant des métis au
québec à être subventionné par le
fédéral en 2020 elle a reçu plus d'un
million de dollars si le gouvernement
fédéral et les provinces les
gouvernements fait d approbation ne
reconnaissent pas à un peuple distinct à
l'est non taillés aussi de l'ontario
québec et cetera et cetera
pourquoi leur donner des financements
ces organismes là que tu viennes
quatrième génération septième génération
tu es métis robert bertrand a été lui
aussi chef de l'alliance autochtone de
2011 à 2016
il a été élu le chef du congrès des
peuples autochtones par la suite j'ai eu
une bonne discussion avec la minus
s'ils voyaient locales ne voulaient pas
nous voir au canada seuls les métis de
l'ouest de la communauté de sault sainte
marie sont reconnus par le fédéral comme
étant des nations autochtones
le congrès des peuples autochtones est
une organisation politique basé à ottawa
qui milite pour la reconnaissance des
autres métiers ce à l'échelle du pays
l'organisation dit aussi représentés
tous les autochtones vivant en réserve
le gouvernement fédéral lui verse près
de 5 millions de dollars par année
si vous définissez comme ils disent et
profond mais je viens vous enlevez la
place des indiens andré maltais a été
député fonctionnaire fédéral pendant
plusieurs années il est celui qui a
convaincu pierre elliott trudeau de
reconnaître les droits des autochtones
dans la charte des droits et libertés
pour lui les organisations représentant
des métis qui ne sont pas reconnus
officiellement par ottawa ne devrait pas
recevoir d'argent public
je comprends ce que tu pour que monsieur
qu'on reste le seul moyen de regarder
sans qu'on les poursuit citoyen on vient
tous mes livres qu'on pense que les
injustices tu peux être à raison
[Musique]
par courriel le ministère des affaires
autochtones dit collaborer avec le
congrès des peuples autochtones dans le
but de faire progresser la
réconciliation
ce que vous votre descendance autochtone
ce qu'ils avaient validé sa remontée à
c'était j'en ai sous les soleils les
deux côtés ce côté paternel côté
maternel qu ils m'ont parlé rapidement
et rapidement gamme asus balma mais là
il change de conversation réduite parce
qu'il veut pas trop qu'on rentre dans
les détails parce qu'en réalité ses
douze générations de la gare mardi selon
nos recherches
l'intendance autochtone de robert
bertrand remonte elle aussi aux années
1600 des gens sont mis en position de
leadership vont rencontrer le
gouvernement fédéral seront niveau pour
différentes raisons
et comme vous l'avez dit vont recevoir
des millions et des millions de dollars
du fédéral
robert bertrand maintient avoir des
ancêtres autochtone contemporain dans sa
lignée sans pouvoir les préciser depuis
son enfance il trappe avec son père dit
il sans autochtone coule dans ses veines
et il se dit fier d'être métis
revenons à notre collaboratrice elle n'a
pas encore reçu sa carte de l'alliance
autochtone mais les surprises
d'apprendre qu'ils répondent aux
critères pour l'obtenir en complétant sa
généalogie
elle découvre une femme autochtone de
noms inconnus cas marié jean nicolet un
proche de samuel de champlain en 1629 le
même enceinte que dominic côté eugénie
bouchard
louis josé houde pierre karl péladeau
est même le premier ministre justin
trudeau
moi aussi je l'aide à mon ascendance
cette femme la seule eau des centaines
de milliers de descendants aujourd'hui
donc si toutes les personnes franco
descendante cd autochtone aujourd'hui
sur une base généalogique
on aurait environ 8 à 10 millions de
nouvelles personnes autochtones au
canada un autre 2 à 3 millions aux états
unis
donc évidemment n'importe qui peut se
dire n'importe quoi si je veux me direz
extra terrestre je peux me dire
extraterrestre la question c'est qui va
te croire après la pause des emplois
réservés aux autochtones dans la
fonction publique sont occupés par des
autochtones autoproclamé j'ai des congés
de maternité donc à chaque retour de
maternité il ya des choses qui se sont
produits jetés comme il y avait des gens
qui étaient devenus autochtones en mon
absence
peut-être que vous vous dites c'est quoi
le problème si quelqu'un se sent
autochtone s'identifie à la culture
autochtone et finit par se présenter
comme autochtones bien vous allez voir
que pour des membres des premières
nations
ça d impact très concret
moi je me souhaite traiter de racistes
sont justement alors que j'ai c'est de
dénoncer les gens qu'ils s'approprient
un peu l'identité autochtone simbi ward
et algonquine et attikameks elle vient
de prendre sa retraite après avoir
travaillé 25 ans auprès des détenus
autochtone elle souhaite dénoncer ce
qu'elle a vu à service correctionnel
canada on m'a approché pour récupère pas
ceux qui disent toujours qu'ils
s'appellent agente de développement
auprès de la collectivité autochtone
donc ça a été le début des initiatives
autochtones aux services correctionnels
[Musique]
ce département des initiatives
autochtone a été mis sur pied pour
répondre aux besoins des détenus issus
des premières nations sur représentés en
milieu carcéral
pour réaliser sa mission service
correctionnel canada a besoin de
personnel autochtone intro tokten est
même obligatoire pour occuper certains
postes clés j'ai eu la chance d'être
maman et puis j'ai des congés de
maternité donc à chaque retour de
maternité il ya des choses qui se sont
produits jeudi comme il y avait des gens
qui étaient devenus autochtones en mon
absence fait que des gens parmi mes
collègues sine die wand de constate
alors que certains collègues déclarent
avoir des origines autochtones pour
obtenir les postes en question
j'ai tellement entendu demi superviseur
dire à quelqu'un oies mais toi tu nous
deux plumes qui peut se nourrir de la
tête le fait que je prêtais mais
tristement cela quelques mois tu sais
des choses que j'ai entendus puis j'ai
pas certaine que cb blague parce que ces
gens là occupé ces fonctions et l'homme
mais certains postes qu'il faut à être
vraiment autochtone pour dominique
launière et malécite de viger l'une des
onze nations autochtones reconnus au
québec elle a travaillé elle aussi au
département des initiatives autochtone
j'avais une collègue qui est encore là
dans la division des initiatives
autochtone qui est d'ascendance
portugaise puis elle est au tour déclaré
uniquement les deux femmes ont tour à
tour déposé une plainte à la commission
de la fonction publique pour dénoncer la
situation mais sans résultat j'ai
dénoncé sort pour que ça cesse
puisqu'elle est détenu puisse bénéficier
des services qui leur sont réservés en
fait
pour obtenir un poste réservé aux
autochtones une personne doit remplir ce
formulaire d'auto identification est
déclarée entre autochtones service
correctionnel canada ne fait aucune
autre vérification supplémentaire
moi j'ai une première nasri de retour et
josé doit constamment prouver que je
suis un autochtone avec ma carte
ce même formulaire de taux identique à
sion est utilisé dans tous les
ministères fédéraux au québec aussi le
formulaire à remplir est relativement
semblable
il n'y a pas que les employés qui ont
des raisons de s'identifier autochtone
les détenus aussi des visites plus
fréquentes des services adaptés et la
possibilité d'obtenir une libération
conditionnelle plus rapidement font
partie des avantages ce qui donne lieu à
des situations étranges
un détenu qui s'auto déclare au top top
8 par la suite et 17 qu'il ait pu coller
il dit à son agent de libération
conditionnelle un élève saumon des
cochons l autochtone dans mon dos aussi
parce que ça me tant qu un autre que ça
pourrait être un détenu qui s'auto
déclaré
ils nous paient trop mots plus tard il
ne mange plus inouï
je suis moi je changeais nation comme
change de chemise
les murs que peu une place importante
dans la culture autochtone dans le
milieu carcéral
ils sont engagés pour aider à la
réhabilitation des détenus sans
importance et je pense que c'est la clé
que les services correctionnels aurait
pu détenir pour travailler vraiment de
façon positive la réinsertion sociale
malheureusement il est arrivé aussi dans
cette sphère l'aude et des autos déclaré
qu'ils ont qui ennuie qui ont nui au
cheminement comme les phares aux
initiatives autochtone donc c'est des
aînés autour d'hekla aurait qui font
passer des entrevues aux nouveaux
ennemis qui veulent
embaucher les deux femmes dénoncent une
situation invraisemblable 1 et n'est pas
vraiment autochtone et un agent de
liaison auto-déclaré sur un formulaire
entrer en relation d'avec un prisonnier
qui n'est pas plus autochtones qu il y
en a beaucoup qui ont quitté
malheureusement il y en a beaucoup qui
ont quitté avec cette amertume le dos
dit ben voyons c'est quoi ça on fabrique
des autochtones aux services
correctionnels service correctionnel
canada a refusé notre demande d'entrevue
par courriel l'organisation affirme que
les employés ont tous droit à l'auto
déclaration et qu'elle n'a pas le
pouvoir de déterminer si une personne
est autochtone ou non service
correctionnel canada et même fier d'être
le plus important employeur
d'autochtones au sein de
l'administration publique centrale fait
les grands perdants bout de ligne ce
sont les premières nations les inuits
parce que la sur représentation ne fait
qu'augmenter et ils ne bénéficient pas
des services auxquels ils ont droit
c'est encore long discrimination
systémique à mon sens à moi qui est
tellement flou locle à la façon tragique
jusqu'au général qui peut définir si que
le club était léger ou métis ou une pour
andré maltais qui a participé à
plusieurs négociations avec les
autochtones
ottawa doit statuer sur une définition
claire de l'identité métis on dit qu'à
peu près 500 milles 1600 olé l'ombre
comme ça c'est qu'on ali nom sonne lino
leur histoire ici on ne leur histoire
ont pu vérifier la validité du jugement
les deux ministre responsable des
affaires autochtones carolyn bennett et
mark miller ont refusé de nous accorder
une entrevue par courriel le ministère
des affaires autochtones se dit
incapable de définir qui est métis et
qui ne l'est pas l'une des raisons un
jugement de la cour suprême en 2016 dans
la sphère daniau le plus haut tribunal a
statué que les métis sont de juridiction
fédérale
ils sont considérés comme des indiens au
sens de la loi constitutionnelle mais
pour obtenir des droits ils doivent
réussir le test parler devant les
tribunaux mais sur l' identité métisse
la cour ne se prononce pas elle laisse
aux métis le soin de se définir eux
mêmes et au gouvernement fédéral la
responsabilité de trancher la décision
d'agneau c'est un peu comme un néant
juridique et ça demeure un énergique
jusqu'à aujourd'hui justement par manque
de clarté
[Musique]
qui est ou n'est pas un métier
aujourd'hui sont ils des survivants des
politiques d'assimilation et du
colonialisme canadien ou des usurpateurs
de l'identité autochtone le débat risque
d'occuper encore longtemps l'espace
public alors que les réseaux sociaux
s'enflamme et que la communauté
universitaire reste divisée
ce que je souhaite c'est la production
de matériel scientifique et historique
plus adéquat sur la question je souhaite
également la prise de dialogue pour que
les gens puissent réaliser que les métis
au québec ou ailleurs c'est pas le
bonhomme sept-heures un dialogue
impossible pour des deux roues qui
persistent à voir dans la mouvance métis
de l'est du pays
une imposture pense qu'il ya de l'espoir
que de plus en plus de franco québécois
de franco ontarien et cetera voit qu'ils
sont en train de nuire aux premiers
peuples qu'ils font confiance au premier
pape leur dise arrêtez de faire cela
mais on peut y notre place nous on est
juste des indigents qui doit était dans
le fonds de réserve puis fermez vos yeux
d'entendre vos réserves si c'est ça le
message kiki c'est ça qu'on vit
présentement
j'aimerais mais tantôt maison qu'on
utiliserait ce point de vue de bénéfices
lors loin de l'opinion leur a appris
très jeune dans vie que ce n'était pas
super des autochtones au canada au
québec comme ailleurs au pays
les associations métis s'organiser
continue d'affirmer leur existence et
leur droit si leur nombre continue
d'augmenter au même rythme les métis
seront plus nombreux que les membres des
premières nations d'ici 15 ans tôt ou
tard le gouvernement devra s'intéresser
à ce phénomène grandissant et tenter de
trouver des solutions
[Musique]
j'espère que vous avez apprécié le
reportage de ce soir au nom de toute
l'équipe
merci beaucoup d'avoir été là je
retrouve la semaine prochaine pour une
autre enquête
je
[Musique]